معنا من مستشفى شهداء الاقصى في دير البلح
مراسل الجزيره هشام زقوط هشام من الواضح
بان قوات الاحتلال تحاول ان توسع عمليتها
من مخيم البريج والنصيرات والمغازي الى
دير البلح كيف ينعكس ذلك على
الارض على الارض استمرار القصف الاسرائيلي
هو سيد الموقف لا سيما من المدفعيه
الاسرائيليه التي تواصل قصف هذه المناطق
المناطق الشرقيه لوسط قطاع غزه لا سما شرق
مخيم البريج وشرق مخيم المغازي بالترافق
مع اعاده تموضع وتمركز لهذه القوات لا سما
في منطقه مخيم البريج حتى الان هذه القوات
توغلت من محور واحد الى تقريبا 2 م من
الحدود الشرقيه الى الاطراف والمناطق
المفتوحه في مخيم البريج وتقصف بعنف هذه
المناطق المنازل المدنيه الفلسطينيه
القريبه من هذه المناطق وعمليه التوغل قبل
ساعه من الان اعادت التموضع والتمركز في
تلك المناطق تراجعت بعض بعض الشيء واعاده
التمركز في على قرب من الحدود الشرقيه
لقطاع غزه القصف ايضا مستمر ومتواصل ما
بين الفينه والاخرى تستهدف الطائرات
المسيره بعض المواطنين لا سما في مخيم
المغازي حيث استهدفت طائره مسيره بعض
المواطنين عند دوار صدقي في مخيم المغازي
ونقل عدد من الاصابات الى مستشفى شهداء
الاقصى هنا في دير البلح لكن منذ نحو ساعه
من الان عمليات القصف هدات عمليات القصف
سواء من المدفعيه او حتى من الطائرات
الحربيه الاسرائيليه كانت ساعات الصباح
ربما تشهد انخفاضا في وتيره القصف
الاسرائيلي لكن منذ بدا الجيش الاسرائيلي
عمليات التوغل في المناطق الوسطى لا سما
في مخيم البريج باتت ساعات الصباح تحمل
الكثير والعديد من الغارات الاسرائيليه لا
سما على المنازل المدنيه الفلسطينيه قب
منذ ساعه من الان لم نرصد اي غاره لم نسمع
اصوات انفجارات ناجمه عن اطلاق القوات
الاسرائيليه للقذائف باتجاه المنازل
المدنيه باتجاه المخيمات القريبه من
السياج الفاصل باتجاه ايضا المناطق
الشماليه لمخيم النصيرات وبالتالي ربما
هذا هدوء يسبق عمليات قصف جديده على هذه
المناطق لا سما وان الطائرات الحربيه
الاسرائيليه ما زالت تحلق ما بين الفينه
والاخرى في سماء المحافظه الوسطى لكن
القصف العنيف والاكثر كثافه هو في خانيونس
الان حيث سمع دوي انفجارات عديده في
خانيونس جنوب قطاع غز وربما هذا القصف هو
الاعنف منذ صباح هذا اليوم لا سما وان
القوات الاسرائيليه ما زالت متوغل في
المناطق الشرقيه لخان يونس ايضا في
المناطق الجنوبيه لخان يونس هناك عمليات
توغل وبالتالي القصف الاسرائيلي مستمر
ومتواصل في هذه المناطق الجيش الاسرائيلي
يحاصر المناطق الشرقيه بني سهيله وخزاعه
والقرار وعبس ويطلق النار على كل ما يتحرك
في تلك المناطق يمنع حتى سيارات الاسعاف
من الوصول الى تلك المناطق وبالتالي من
يصاب من يستشهد في تلك تلك المناطق لا
يستطيع الخروج الى المستشفى ولا حتى
المواطنين بانفسهم كما كان يجري بسيارات
مدنيه يمكن كانوا ان ينقلوه الى
المستشفيات ولكن الجيش الاسرائيلي يواصل
اطلاق النار على تلك المناطق ايضا محيط
المستشفى الاوروبي شهد غارات عنيفه من قبل
الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه وايضا اطلقت
المدفعيه على في المناطق الشرقيه قذائف
باتجاه هذه المناطق القريبه من هذا
المستشفى ومستشفى الاوروبي ربما هو واحد
من المستشفيات التخصصيه الاكبر في قطاع
غزه لا سما وان الكثير من الاصابات في
مستشفيات صغيره كمستشفى شهداء الاقصى
ومستشفى ابو يوسف النجار في رفح تحول الى
مستشفى الاوروبي وبالتاكيد اطلاق هذه
القذائف في محيط هذا المستشفى يعيق عمليه
تحويل المصابين لا سما الذين اصيبوا
باصابات خطيره الى هذا المستشفى بالتالي
هي عمليات قصف متتاليه في اكثر من منطقه
من قطاع غزه كما استمعنا في جباليه كما
استمعنا ايضا في مدينه غزه حي الشجاعيه
وحي التفاح وحي الدرج يتعرضون الى قصف
عنيف ايضا من المدفعيه وعمليات التوغل
مازال تزال مستمره بالاضافه الى الغارات
المتفرقه ما بين الفينه والاخرى في اكثر
من محافظه في قطاع غز شكرا لك هشام سقوط
مراسل جزيره كنت معنا من مستشفى شهداء
الاقصى في دير
البلح